maruti used to work as a freelance
journalist but now he is the press
officer for italy at the european
parliament this week he is in Strasburg
for the plenary session where it's you
who has been blind since birth takes a
special interest in one of the items on
the MEP agenda if I hadn't had a
computer provided with equipped with
assistive technology I wouldn't be able
to be here today to do the job I'm doing
I wouldn't have been able to be a
journalist even so there are still many
internet sites that are not accessible
for disabled people or elderly Mauricio
has often ran into trouble if you have
to pay a bill that maybe you want to
select the period the way you want to
give you know your your actual
consumption and you cannot make it
because maybe I don't know you cannot
click on the submit button the European
Parliament wants to make it mandatory
for all public sector organisations to
run web sites that are accessible to
everyone according to the MEP deterrence
over 80 million disabled people would
benefit from this we will get rid of the
bizarre situation when people are asked
to pay their taxes online by the website
is not accessible to all citizens it
will help also employees there working
place because all the information
intranet will have to be accessible to
them also to mothers did want to follow
the websites of the schools Mauricio and
all the disabled person this is only a
first step that should be followed by
website accessibility of the private
sector ecommerce insurance and banking
right